In Dante's inferno.
I think I mentioned this at one point.
So Dante's inferno,
it's a very interesting story.
It's a descent into hell a,
and it's actually one of the places
that we sort of derive the popular
conception of hell was
partly based on Dante's,
on Dante's imagination,
on his work.
And what Dante was trying to do was to
discover the hierarchical structure of
evil.
And you know,
you might think there is a
hierarchical structure of good,
some things are better than other things,
but there's also a
hierarchical structure of evil.
Some evils are greater than other
evils and he put betrayal in the,
in the,
in the lowest part of Hail,
right?
So if you were betraying people,
you were right beside Satan himself.
And so,
and I think that's good.
That's very smart.
While Dante was a genius after all,
um,
and I think the reason
for that is that you see,
if someone trusts you,
they're laying their
vulnerability open to you.
Now they might just be naive,
let's say.
And that's,
we won't think about that
because you're just a child.
If you're naive,
you can still be betrayed.
But if you're an adult and you trust,
it's often because you,
if you're an actual adult,
it's you willingly open yourself
up knowing that you could be hurt.
Right?
Cause you're not naive anymore.
So you decide to trust and you see y'all
opened myself up and I know that I'm
laying myself open to you.
If you choose to use that power and
then that's a good thing to know.
You know,
if you've been hurt as a child,
it hurt as a naive person.
You might say,
well why should I ever trust again?
Which is a really good question.
And the answer is the reason you trust,
again,
once you're an adult is
because you're courageous.
You're,
you're courageous.
It's an act of courage to trust.
And the reason it's useful is
because if you trust someone,
you opened the door to reciprocity and
negotiation and cooperation and you
entice the best part
of the person forward.
And so it's a,
it's a courageous act.
But then if you be traced someone,
then what you've done is you've
taken the best part of them,
which is the part that
will courageously trust,
you know,
with open eyes.
Right?
And you've stuck a dagger in that.
And so you've purposefully
damaged the best part of the,
and so that's why it's
such a egregious fault.
And,
and it's often people don't recover
from that sort of playing it.
You,
if you'd be traced someone badly enough,
you can,
you can damage them.
Like you can give them post traumatic
stress disorder if you really,
if you really put your mind to it,
and you know,
that's not just a psychological disorder.
If you have posttraumatic stress disorder,
it produces permanent neurological
alterations that make you more neurotic,
more sensitive to negative emotion,
really for the rest of your life.
Like you can,
you can recover from it to some degree,
but stress will tend to
re instantiate that PTSD.
So you,
you hurt someone and
it's not merely cycle.
Not that psychological is merely,
but it's not merely psychological,
right?
It's,
it's fundamental physiological damage.